- Oh, I probably have as big
an ego as anybody, you know.
(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] Well hey
there, look, it's Willie.
- [Voiceover] 30 years ago, a
chess match with Ray Charles
taught a very confident
Willie a lesson in humility.
- Ray and I were doing a show in Austin,
he was staying over at the hotel,
and I went over to say
hello, he comes to the door,
we walked in, there was a little
light in the hallway there,
then we walked into the living
room, there was no light.
And he sat down here and I sat down there,
he got out the chess board.
And his chess pieces were
all, there were no color,
they were all the same color,
unpainted wood, you know?
But he could feel of 'em
and tell what they were.
- [Voiceover] Hey, hey, hey.
- So needless to say, he
kicked my ass about three games
in a row and I said thank
you, Ray, let's go sing.
♫ Whoa, I believe they were prayin’
♫ Prayin’ for the lovers
♫ Yeah they was ♫
- But I didn't tell him that
the next time we played,
I wanted to do it with
the lights on (laughs).
(mellow piano music)